it's great to welcome to the program
today Rob Larson who's a professor of
economics as well as author of
capitalism versus freedom and the
forthcoming bit tyrants from Haymarket
books so great to have you on Rob I
appreciate it
that's great thanks David I'm excited so
I guess to begin with
why are we so terrible at number one
learning the lessons of past recessions
and number two predicting future ones
and I recognize that the answers to
those two questions may be different but
maybe that'll be like an entry point
into our conversation for sure yeah well
they're learning our lessons from past
recessions that's kind of difficult
because you know they are like irregular
it's really reliable that in a market
economy will have recurring periods
where the economy shrinks instead of
growing like capitalism usually does we
call that the recession periods the
thing is they're really irregular and
you can go for long stretches without a
recession or have them relatively quick
intervals and they can be short
themselves or long or harsh or soft and
this is the longest-running economic
expansion in American post-war history
here the Obama Trump expansion such as
it is so because they have that sort of
inconsistent sort of unpredictable
nature it's kind of easy for people to
put them to the side plus when the
economy grows people make more money and
that tends to erase the human memory a
little bit and then in terms of
predicting future ones I mean you know
it's very easy to say we're one day
closer today to the next recession than
we were yesterday and because of the
system that we have it's true unless
we've now unless we're never again going
to have one but are there particular
indicators that you think are more
useful to figuring out when a recession
is coming than others for sure and you
know the whole field of macroeconomics
is just completely devoted to studying
this problem and analyzing the ups and
downs of the market you know what they
call the business cycle and it has a
mixture of success usually it's good in
more stable conditions than ones where
we have sharp changes shows you the
limits of our economics prediction
powers as a science as far as the
indicators right now though I would
agree with what everyone's
saying about the picture which is that
sort of mixed signals right now we have
a number of warning lights that are
flashing I wrote about this recently for
current affairs like right now there's a
inversion of the US government bond
yield curve which is a big ominous
development freak on it's a little
technical you can read about it in the
article but meanwhile we are seeing
extremely low unemployment rates but
because of the really inconsistent
unpredictable nature of the trade war
we've started it's starting to spook
consumers and not just investors which
has been happening all this time so it's
a mixed picture right now and often we
don't know that we're in a recession
until it's really clear so one of the
things that in a hyper partisan sort of
model is important to lots of people
is to attribute blame or responsibility
when things are good to presidents for
how the economy is doing and we could
sort of divide I mean we could imagine
okay the full list of actions the
president takes and we could evaluate
them on the basis of their sort of
logistical nuts and bolts economic
impact and then we could also evaluate
them on the confidence or or lack
thereof that they inspire and how that
can have an effect on the economy so to
kind of get into this topic at the
presidential level do this how much are
the decisions that a president makes
important from a sort of fundamentals
perspective and how much are they
important to the economy from a
perception and confidence perspective
Yeah right on well obviously those both
do play a real role and you're right
like people are really partisan about
their views of the President
whatever presidential administration it
is in the economy if things are good the
presidential supporters will say thanks
to the president and if not they'll say
well the president doesn't really make
policy for the economy which is true so
people are partisan but obviously
Congress has the main economic power
there the legislation allegis later
bodies along with some influenced by the
larger economic ax the economically
larger US states but of course the
presidency has grown so much over the
recent decades it has really economic
muscle obviously for decades the State
Department you know in the
administration
how is the tariff making Authority they
used to belong to the Congress
previously that's a major change just in
the last few decades that people don't
even remember that didn't used to be in
the president's power to do this for
better or worse so the president clearly
does have some influence especially
these days plus I mean the military
system alone is a major system of
subsidies and so on so real influence
there but it's true like economics has
psychology enix it's about human beings
and as investors and as consumers and
obviously as workers and if people feel
like there's an unsteady or too like
weirdly inconsistent hand at the helm of
the ship it's true that it will like
spook them maybe a little maybe a lot
and it changes over time but right now
investors have been cutting off
investments because of how incredibly
unpredictably these tariffs and the
trade conflicts have been managed and if
that gradually spreads into like the
actual consumer economy which makes up
about two-thirds of American demand in
the marketplace that's the way we could
really see this tilt into a recession
quickly in a recession governments have
different tools that they can use to try
to encourage certain types of behavior
or to make the recession less acute for
example so there are sort of New Deal
type policies government jobs programs
you can do interest rate changes there
can be a stimulus done I mean there's
all of these things in different
proportions and combinations exist and
many others is there a particular
prescription that you think is the best
one in a modern economy for making a
recession less severe or less long
potentially for sure there are standard
tools that are you know have been known
to fiscal and monetary policymakers in
various arms of the government for years
and again they have sort of a mixed
record but clearly like since World War
two got us out of the depression it's
been known you can use government
spending or tax cuts depending on the
specifics to stimulate as we say the
economy to give it a fiscal policy boost
if the private sector is contracting
because it's a recession and there
laying off people and closing down
investments well the state can hire them
and the government can hire you to make
bombs World War two it could hire you to
abate our horrible horrible climate
legacy that we're leaving so you could
have a traditional New Deal which of
course refers to the big 30s policy
programs for public employment and
fixing our many many social and
infrastructure problems at the same time
at the cost of deficit spending or of
course taxing the rich but these days
obviously the thing looming in a lot of
our minds is that we are just actively
destroying the environmental system and
all the ecosystem services as ecologists
say yeah we dig into that a little
because so you mentioned climate there
are all sorts of I don't know that I
call them behaviors but characteristics
of the economic system that we have that
on the Left we want to try to deal with
so like the way we're destroying the
climate and the invite climate
instability as a result of human
activity would be one example monopoly
power in giant industries to the
detriment of consumers is something we
would want to deal with more sort of
this elite ownership class that is
making money off of money relative to
workers with stagnant wages like in a
normal thing any social democrat like me
would say we want to deal with this
stuff have you studied and I have not so
I'm curious have you studied whether
during times of recession a lot of those
things sort of go by the wayside more
more acceptable II because the priority
becomes we've all got to get out of this
recession and it can actually reinforce
the destruction of the environment
concentration of wealth etc absolutely
and yeah I'm very sad to say if someone
you know who shares a lot of those
left-wing views and as someone who
really believes in democracy and thinks
that we should expand it to the economy
and have nice socialist ideas like that
it hurts to know that during recessions
or just difficult economic times because
during this this last long expansion
very little of the growth has gone to
the middle classes like the working and
professional classes so in whatever
conditions when people are struggling
it's a drag to me to learn that it is
in opinion survey and analysis that
people's you know support for
environmental laws of different types
does wane when the economy struggles
especially at that level of the job
market of people's incomes that's a
relatively well-documented thing I know
I've heard n would talk about this so
people can look into it but sadly it is
the case no it's not like it collapses
and definitely concern about these
issues is on the rise overall in the
long run but during recessions we do
tend to see a drop in concern about this
kind of thing like environmental issues
or support for issues like racial
equality people are more willing to
support that if they don't see that
support as coming from a limited basis
that they survive on already so it's
breaking out of that kind of specific
you know the environment versus my
well-being framework which we've got to
get out of that to me is the genius of
the green New Deal framework in general
and a lot of the specific proposals that
have come out of Sanders campaign
obviously representative Acacio Cortez's
office you can read those proposals
online they're not huge and unreadable
like your insurance documents are
they're actually things that you can
comprehend that is something that
despite Fox News's will has become
widely recognized as a possibility of
hiring people through taxing the rich to
help us change the energy system clean
up our mess rebuild the infrastructure
that has been collapsing all around us
for decades that's that green New Deal
framework that could get us out of that
specific kind of unsustainable trade-off
meant mindset that you're talking about
last thing I wanted to touch on you know
very it's completely reasonable and
expected that economists often don't
dabble in personal finance in any way
and that's totally reasonable but I'm
curious in whether in your study of
recessions you have come across sort of
any particular activities or decisions
that at the individual consumer level
can be good ones to make obviously
without giving anyone financial advice
you know the things I often talk about
and my background is in financial
planning are you always want to be
living within your means even when the
times are good so that then you know
you're building savings and when times
are bad you don't all of a sudden have a
shock to the system that you've gotta
just because you're living beyond your
means you want to if you can it all
avoid it avoid taking losses when the
the economy is not good because
historically over the long run you
recover for example so are there any
things you've observed that at the
consumer level seem to be logical ones
to do during bad economic times oh
absolutely you know I mean there are
things of course that we can do most of
us are Americans and have various
different kinds of privilege which can
play a role I mean obviously like you
said living within your means is the
best thing you can do to the extent that
you can trim unnecessary spending on
your fancier cocktails or maybe travel
that you could postpone like those are
natural common-sense steps that you can
take during at times of recession or
when you're between jobs and I think
that's very reasonable
I teach a lot of young people and
counseling and helping people plan their
careers and think about their financial
problems as part of the process what we
realize doing that is that there are of
course we all know limits to what you
can personally prepare for and plan for
so when you have a major medical event
like you crash your car or you have an
appendectomy
dude yes those things happen if you have
limited if you don't have insurance or
have limited bad American private sector
insurance with big deductibles and
co-pays and coinsurance and network
coverage limits and so on there's a
ceiling to how much you can prepare for
it yeah you get medical prices can just
wipe you out immediately and this is why
I always you know the lot a millionaire
things if you just skipped your drink
every week you'd be able to retire in
five years or whatever I always think
it's important to contextualize that in
you know if college the cost of college
has become completely out of whack with
salaries and predatory student lending
and the potential of a medical
bankruptcy are there you know the the
avoiding that a lot a here there is not
really going to be what makes or breaks
it it's going to be systemic economic
change that needs to happen
absolutely and Suze Orman and her creepy
eyes can kind of be apply that it's
because of people's coffee bills that
Millennials have all this debt yeah it's
bonkers it's from school and from what
medical problems people complies ibly
expect so that's why the
issues that you just referred to like
that are systemic so you know the
existence of a elite class that sort of
owns not just most of the household
wealth but they own the stock in the big
monopolistic corporations from
technology to the old economy like
that's where the wealth of our society
is sort of locked up and those are
systemic issues like we deal with that
with mass movements and supporting a
Sanders campaign or the like your local
leftist candidates you'll need your
support but it's at that level that the
real change can come because right you
know I have known many students who are
earnest and frugal and they're mature
for their age and they don't overspend
and they have a mild medical episode or
just the cost of borrowing even to go to
a community college becomes so crushing
that it really reduces their standard of
living and exactly if they lose a job in
a recession you can be really stuck
because of that so that's why we need
that national kind of change let me talk
about we've been speaking with rob
Larson who's a professor of economics
and author of capitalism versus freedom
and the forthcoming bit tyrants from
Haymarket books Rob really appreciate
your time today
thanks mats my pleasure